a major concern for state leaders as the
covet 19 vaccine rollout continues in
nevada is
equity that's because certain groups are
not getting enough shots
organa explains how advocates are tech
or tackling
on the issue we need to do a little bit
better
health advocates want to enhance equity
in clark county's distribution of the
covet 19 vaccine the latest numbers from
the southern nevada health district show
41 percent of vaccines have been given
to white residents
while only 10 percent have been given to
hispanics and 6 percent
to african americans we have been
working on developing a task force
erica marquez with the nevada minority
health and equity coalition is trying to
make a difference she says certain
minority groups aren't getting enough
vaccines
partially because of vaccine hesitancy
and a lack of information
we are going to be looking at you know
kind of those really important
components about the communication
pieces like how are we disseminating
information into the community that's
why they're releasing these videos and
hosting webinars but there are also
barriers with making appointments since
not everyone has access to technology
it can't be solely just on an electronic
means governor steve sislak recently
announced a vaccine
equity initiative because health
district data also shows the zip codes
in clark county with the highest number
of copit 19 cases
have some of the lowest frequency of
vaccinations
that makes no sense these zip codes
represent southern nevada's working
class families
lower income households the state is
working to expand outreach to those
groups and marquez is ready to help
we're excited to kind of work hand in
hand with the governor
orco mana 8 news now